hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested and I said I
was gonna cover it but you know I
haven't had had time up until now it's a
game from the extra con open we've been
following the success of programming on
des and white rally so we haven't really
been checking up on any other games from
extra con but now it's time for me to
show - it's really amazing truly you
know a hidden gem gem of the tournament
it's played between ukrainian
grandmaster alexandra moisei Inco and
the danish international master Cossack
or lay also known as Casablanca so
without further ado let's just check it
out as its well quite quite a game so
Machine Co opens with d4 we have d5 c4
e6 Knight to c3 and Knight to f3
so the Queens gambit is on the board and
we have an early trade in the center C
captures each captures and now Bishop to
g5 unlike Lasker musain who prefers to
develop his dark square Bishop before
finishing up the pawn chain so c6 as now
the bishop earth threatens the night you
wanna enhance the defense in the center
so c6 defends the d5 pawn with III now
finishing up the pawn chain and here
Bishop to d6 by Corley it's interesting
as we've covered today already
Capablanca versus last for game 8 of the
roaches championship we said that the
bishop to f5 was very nice by capablanca
as you always have problems developing
the light square bishop so here you
could play Bishop f5 preventing Bishop
to d3 but then white can go into the
Queen f3 line your Bishop is under
attack and after you give you the busway
and move your Bishop back to g6 which
only makes sense you don't want to move
it back to where it came from
now we just capture and after this
capture you get to this position where
blacks pawn structure is all messed up
here's three point island say you're
gonna play knight 92 are gonna go g3 90s
coming to f4 and you're just gonna have
a very nice position with white so it is
possible I don't think it's it's good
for black so that's one of the reasons
why you don't develop it - like this
even though you would seemingly
try and get away with the development of
the light squares but ok
the d6 by quarreling with Bishop to d3
and the now comes castles and Queen to
c2 now already with the threat just
capturing on f6 and picking up the h7
pawn so Corley a defends with h6 pushing
the bishop back with the shocked h4 and
now rook to e8 just nicely developing
the White King is still in the center
with 90 G to e2 preparing the castle who
knows maybe King said maybe Queen side
we'll see what happens and correlate
pushes a5 now of course you don't want
to Castle queenside white already black
already started expanding on the Queen
side and another thing Corley has done
preparing Knight to a6 which makes sense
you do have a queen and the bishop here
so nice to b4 is the idea after a3 is
plate to prevent night before the knight
can be driven over to c7 and from c7 the
Knight has a lot of useful squares so
first h3 before castling you want to
take away the g4 Square from blacks
pieces and now there is one game in the
database for Knight bTW 7 was played but
here Corley goes for night to a6 and now
it is as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game and white white to
move so of course you have to prevent
Bishop Knight before you don't want to
allow an attack against the Queen and
the Bishop you're going to lose your
light square Bishop which is a pretty
awesome piece here so a3 and now just
remembering the knight c7 the knight is
now coming to e6 from there you can come
to g5 and if black doesn't want to give
FY doesn't want to give up the bishop
pair you can maybe even play Knight to
e4 which would be quite an
accomplishment
so with castles by Corley and now nice
to East 6 and here we have f3 taking
away not only the g4 square but also the
e4 square from blacks pieces and now
even after this night comes the g5 you
don't really have a 4 and another thing
this f3 move does is it prepares efore
as white wants to play e4 as soon as
possible so here Coralie finds a very
nice maneuver Knight to g5 and hear what
you have to play with white is f4 and
black will realize that the e4 square is
not available
because if you play Knight to e4 for
example Knight g4 then you white will
just capture it and after D captures yes
for the moment ok d4 pawn is
defended about 93 and now both nights
and the Queen are attacking the pawn
here next move white we'll just pick it
up and there's nothing black can do to
prevent it you can't go Bishop f5 DF v
square is defended by tonight so f4
would have been best here but then again
f4 is such an unnatural move to play
after f4 you live such you you know
leave such a huge hole and on e4 for
blacks pieces it's unnatural but here
you have to do it but moisture anko
dozen did not play it for he played Eve
for which makes sense you know a nice
central breakthrough you're threatening
a 5-2 win material here why not but it
doesn't work so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find why it
doesn't work in the what Coral a had
prepared here well I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations the position
for white is definitely not unassailable
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show black here play tonight F
captures on e4
so just grabbing that point and here
you're asking white what are you gonna
do if you don't capture the night with F
captures on e4 then you just lost the
point whatever white plays you're gonna
capture on c3 and you're gonna say thank
you for the pawn
yeah you've obviously missed this which
moistening co did miss and here he
wanted to hang on to everything but it's
a you have to capture it there's no way
around it here he played F captures on
e4 and now most likely you found this
area because you saw that the bishop on
h4 is undefended and this is the point
of the combination here quarterly plays
Knight captures on h3 with check and now
the next move Queen will pick up the
Bishop on h4 so you play G captures on
h3 and now Queen captures on h4 so
already Black has a wonderful attack he
sacrificed a piece those the the bishop
pair is nicely slicing over to the to
the king side if you can get the rook
into the attack it's gonna be really
awesome for example rookie 6-2 gg6 check
there's not much this White King can do
so here how do you defend it's not all
that clear for example b5
losses to the very
the rook captures on g5 so there's no
real really no way to fend off the
bishop pair if it captured Bishop c5
check and you're just getting destroyed
here there's no defense here the bishops
are doing all the work the Queen slices
all the way here if you're looking each
student just Queen captures on h3 is
checkmate so a very delicate position
here moisten completely rook to f2
trying to get his King to start to
running away but you know it's very
unlikely that you will be able to do
this here Bishop captures on h3 was
played if you play Queen captures on h3
you might think ok it's the same idea
I'm just gonna play something like this
it's not the same because here White has
a 5 and the difference is now if you try
this rook captures pawn care for some
Bishop c5 the rook already prevents
check so it's white to move you're just
gonna play nice d1 and now I white
already black already sacrificed a lot
of material if you don't have mate
you're just gonna lose and for example
the Queen is now attacking the bishop
you don't want to trade here you're down
material so Bishop a7 and now Knight to
f4 kicking the Queen away Queen g3 check
it's not a problem King f1 and black has
no way of continuing the attack
successfully so here white would be able
to fend off the attack and it's not a
problem so here you have to be
absolutely precise on what you do bush
of characters and h3 introducing another
piece into the attack and here it's hard
to defend the engines give Knight
captures on d5 but it's still not good
enough for white after C captures now e5
and ok you do block some of the
attackers but still Bishop e7 can come
to g5 to e3 and still it's it's very
unpleasant for white however much the
anko played rook a to d1 and it does
make sense you want to play root D - you
were to help out with the defense of the
rook here you want to move the night but
this losses terribly as now you've seen
that had the crucial defense against the
rook c5 was that this Knight was coming
to the d1 square
now after rook to d1 was played this no
longer exists and this of course allows
Corley his next move which of course I
don't have to tell you what it is
it's rook to e5 and
you can see that the bishop slices over
this way this bishop slices over this
way the queen controls the h-file rogue
g5 check will be deadly so how do you
prevent this of course you have to
capture the rogue there's no other way
these chapters on e5 was played
we have Bishop to c5 now putting
pressure on the rook here Queen captures
is the threat you don't have a good way
of dealing with this as the rook on d1
is now preventing the knight from coming
here to add another defender to the f2
square so here you have to move this
night so the Queen protects the rook so
here Knight the d4 was played you might
be thinking why give up the night
there's no point in doing this you could
try simply night to c1 this doesn't work
there's the reason why we're saying
could play 94 because here Queen g3 is
the idea the of course the the rook is
pinned you cannot move it and after king
h1
now you capture and now only the Queen
defends the f2 square so you're not
really defending anything and next move
it's checkmate or you're gonna have
severe material loss so nice the d4
instead and now comes the bishop capture
Sun before but now rogue deters okay now
the Queen the rook and the king the
guard ef-2 square but it's still not
enough
Queens the g3 check we have King - h1
only move and now Bishop to g4 the
thread is Bishop to f3 check and then
after rook captures the bishop will be
guarding the G 1 square so Queen to g1
will be made that's the threat so white
prevented it with Bishop to f1 now
preparing to meet Bishop to f3 check
with Bishop to g2 but it's not enough
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find a nice mating sequence for
black it's a really nice soul I'll give
you a couple of seconds once again for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
mater in 3 on the kingside and for those
of you just wanna enjoy the show
Bishop f3 check with the shop - G - ok
this was planned but now you will not be
able to capture the Queen Queen to h3
check and it was in this position that
ukrainian grandmaster alexander muy
saying ho resigned to the game he
resigned as there is only
one move here of course you cannot
capture we already mentioned to do to
the pin here the point is bring the king
over to G 1 so the rook is pinned so
King G 1 would have to be played and now
you can play Queen captures and G 2 and
you have this beautiful mate where the
rook is unable to capture the Queen due
to the nice spin by the dark square
bishop here so this is the power of the
bishop pair once again nicely
demonstrated by the by the Danish
International Master Casablanca here and
it really just reminded me the the
powerful attack on the King side of the
I believe it's 1957 Soviet championship
we covered this game boogity gorgonites
vs mikhail tal were tall unleashed a
month monstrosity of an attack on the
Kings side similar to this one although
it did involve the Queen sacrifice if
you haven't seen it I will put it in the
description below it will be the first
thing you see so if you haven't seen the
game Gorgon it's a versus Michael tall -
check it out it's an old video I know
it's hard to watch my videos in only 30
frames per second but it's a nice game
I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it
and also I would just like to mention
that Cossack Orly also has a youtube
channel
so do check it out it will be the second
link in the description below if you
enjoy well if you've enjoyed his game
maybe you will also enjoy his channel
maybe learn how to play in such a nice
style he doesn't have many videos I
believe he only has six videos so far he
has a playlist wrote the Grandmaster so
he's trying to become a Grandmaster I
think he achieved his first Grandmaster
normal already but maybe he will also
cover this game on his channel so you
know you're welcome to check it out and
maybe wait for that if it will happen I
have no idea but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it like I said do
check out Gorgon it's a versus style
really just a beautiful beautiful game I
would like to thank Jeff grapes
Jeff graves Fabian Wieck dominic wait
for it constantinos covered Sao Paulo's
n dogs and Romano's for a contributor to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video serie think all for
watching and I will see you soon
checking up in your suggestions such as
this one so thank you for that
continuing the Capablanca saga and well
checking whatever happens in the chess
world thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday